The Belgian capital of Brussels is a city buzzing with life,...
...cosmopolitan but with a historic heart.
Brussels is home to some world famous sites and some quirky surprises.
Begin with a coach tour of the city,...
...making stops along the way to capture the sights and scenery on camera.
See one of Europe's most famous landmarks, The Atomium,...
...built for the 1958 World Fair.
This Space Age structure was only intended to stand for a year,...
...but its popularity ensured it remains, still gleaming over half a century later.
Moving on, you'll see the elegant Royal Palace and the European Parliament,...
...the political heart of Europe.
Arriving at the Old Town,...
...leave the coach to begin a walk through the labyrinth of narrow streets.
Experience the bustle of Butcher's Street...
...and admire the sophisticated shops in Saint-Hubert Arcade,...
...the world's first covered shopping gallery.
The centerpiece of the Old Town is the spectacular Grand Place...
...with its gothic Renaissance and Baroque facades.
This is one of the finest squares in the world.